non mais c'est vrai je pense que vous y
êtes allé pour faire des Tik Tok c'était
une manif contre la réforme des
retraites ça aurait été une manif contre
les trottinettes vous y seriez allé
aussi c'est la même chose si tu es
obligé de filmer c'est
pareil je suis désolé moi je vois des
milliers des millions de manifestants
dans toute la France ils ont des
pancartes avec des messages pas des
perches à selfies et au lieu de vous
demander quand est-ce que vous allez
partir à la retraite demandez-vous quand
est-ce que vous avez commencé un vrai
boulot plutôt c'est ça ah oui
[Applaudissements]
ça n'est pas tout en même temps
Toutatice oui on est pas obligé d'être
concerné pour manifester non mais nos
grands-parents on voit nos enseignants
on voit totalement
manifester mais non mais vous avez droit
mais il fester vous avez le droit de
mettre les tenues que vous voulez je
pense juste que vous faites ça encore
une fois pour faire des Tik Tok pour
faire du buzz pour créer une polémique
pour re répondre à la polémique et pour
gagner des abonnés etc je veux juste ça
moi me tenir ils le font pas il y a un
problème ils le font il y a un problème
est-ce que vous pensez que vous êtes
concerné est-ce que vous pensez que vous
travaillez on n'est pas concerné
toujours dans 10 ans je vais te
caissière on sait pas ce serait très
bien bah oui
aussi non mais non mais